Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Gotham we got a major reference to Bane
and Venom from the comics as well as the darker
corners of Wayne Enterprises.
So just like normal I’ll start with my top
5 comic book moments and the do my review.
Hello any new people.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time, I’m doing all the DC TV shows, so
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
It’s a really awesome time for comic book
tv right now.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Wayne Enterprises is Vast and somewhat
corrupt
The real villains here are the board members.
At this point they’re the faceless power
behind Viper and Venom.
There’s this really interesting relationship
between the super wealthy people in Gotham
and the big mobsters like Falcone and Maroni.
Some of the villains operate at night, some
during the day in an office.
But they’re all bad.
I don’t know if they specifically intended
to draw any references, but think of the Wayne
Board Members as a Nest of Vipers.
And yes, I do think that Wellzyne person at
the end is connected to one or more of the
board members.
I don’t think she was working for Falcone
or Maroni.
Someone we haven’t met yet.
And don’t forget that a lot of the movies
and tv shows have sprung supervillains from
inside Wayne Enterprises.
In
the movies, The Riddler worked for Bruce Wayne
and I’m pretty sure Wayne also owned Axis
chemicals where the Michael Keaton Joker was
created.
I think in the comics the name was ACE Chemicals
and it was the Kane family that owned it.
The Kane family is where Bruce’s Mother
comes from, her maiden name was Martha Kane.
In the comics they own everything the Wayne’s
didn’t already own pretty much.
So when she married Thomas Wayne it was like
the two richest people ever getting together.
I don’t know if Gotham is going to address
the Kane family.
But Gordon’s former fiancee Barbara is a
Kean, and they’re another super rich family.
Number 4 - The Russian Mob
In the comics the Russian Mob has worked a
lot with Black Mask.
On the show it seems like the Russian is just
a puppet in Mooney’s coup against Falcone.
There was a man in a mask in the Halloween
promo the ran after the episode, but I don’t
think it’s going to be black mask.
The big thing on the show has been showing
people before they became the big comic book
characters.
Number 3 - Gotham University
This appeared in the comics for the first
time in 1941.
In more recent years it’s where Batgirl
goes to school when she’s not fighting crime.
There was also another student who became
Bat-Devil and a new version of Azrael.
Bruce is way too young on the show to go there
now, but it’s possible for them to say that
some batman villains work there or are students.
The big origin locations for batman villains
on the show are probably going to be Arkham,
Wayne Enterprises and Gotham U.
Number 2 - World’s Greatest Detective
Bruce is supposed to be somewhere between
11 and 13 on the show.
I give them a blanket pass on how clever he’s
allowed to be.
Batman isn’t a genius, he’s just intelligent
and never stops working.
He’s like the king of homework.
Or Detective work.
Almost the same thing.
Two of my favorite scenes in the episode were
when he was first putting together his evidence
chart.
I guess he hasn’t commissioned his super
computer yet.
And at the end when Alfred joins him really
excitedly.
Like Alfred finally gets that this is something
important for Bruce to do.
Batman is a bit of an obsessive compulsive
when it comes to solving mysteries, so they
might take the character there this season.
Like make him go a little nuts pushing himself
too hard.
Alfred’s role is really to balance him out
emotionally.
Like slap him back to sanity when he gets
too crazy.
and my Number 1 comic book moment - Venom
They said it was stable in the episode, so
Wellzyne has a working formula.
I think the question now is what is the show
going to do with it.
Maybe nothing right now.
Venom gets into Bane from the comics and I
don’t see the show doing him any time soon.
The villains of this episode were trying to
show people how awful it was.
In a really misguided crackpot way.
I think there’s someone on the Wayne Board
that’s controlling Wellzyne though and they’ll
be one of the bigger villains this season.
It’s possible the Wayne’s murder, Arkham
City and Wellzyne are all connected.
There’s still a lot of characters the show
needs to introduce, so we’ll have a better
picture for who all the players are by the
middle of the season in a couple weeks.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
though and what did you think of the Viper
special effects.
They kind of reminded me of the Venom effects
from the Batman and Robin movie, with Bane’s
body twisting and growing.
There were a few other easter eggs I spotted
to:
Bruce Wayne being into old Zorro flicks.
Masked man and all.
And Bette Kane.
She was supposed to be in the episode, or
people were saying she was.
She was the original Bat Girl in the comics,
and imdb is listing Sara Paxton in 17 episodes.
There are only going to be 22 episodes this
season.
So I guess she’ll be on the show next week
unless there’s some kind of error or something
big has changed.
Overall I gave the episode a B, I felt like
the Bruce Detective story line was the strongest.
The Venom parts got a little bit silly but
I think it will turn into something much much
bigger once we learn who the board members
are.
I think the gallon of milk challenge
was a clear sign that we were supposed to
laugh a little.
We also saw a lot more David Mazouz, I like
his version of public Bruce Wayne.
There’s the public persona he takes on when
he’s being Bruce Wayne Billionaire and then
there’s the Detective persona when he’s
being Batman.
That’s why he seemed so patient with the
Wellzyne woman when he asked about the Board.
He was just playing it cool.
The catwoman scene felt a little out of place
and I feel like they could have tightened
things by just cutting out that food truck.
It still feels like they’re spending a lot
of time setting up big arcs.
They want us to feel like Mooney versus Falcone
will be a big title fight and visually that
final scene was amazing.
But I don’t feel like Mooney or her girl
on the inside are very threatening.
It’s hard to stand out as a batman villain
if you’re not wearing clown makeup and randomly
slicing people’s mouths open.
Next week is going to be a halloween episode,
so I have high hopes for some craziness.